hey
guys what's up we're back with more date
fails i'm kate quigley
i have the hilarious comedian and my
very very hot and uh
i want to say a little vulgar vulgar a
little a little vulgar i'm disgusting
a little disgusting jessica michelle
singleton what's up girl hi thanks for
having me
thank you for being here i'm i'm super
pumped i feel like i never see you that
much anymore oh i never run into you
we're both busy it's good things it's a
great thing we're both doing a lot you
were just saying you have a whole
month of touring africa yeah i'm going
to south africa in november
i'm down the road a lot i've been out of
town a ton and i come back and i have
this weird thing of
thinking it's other people that have
been gone i'll run into people and be
like where have you been i'm the same i
do the same thing and they're like you
haven't been around right
they're like you left do you panic ever
when you're gone
that people will like kind of just
forget about you here
you know what no oh that then forget i
said it no i think that's really normal
because everyone else asked me that and
i'm like i think
i'm so out of sight out of mind that
like i probably
forget about everyone else so i forget
that they can forget about me you're
hard to forget though
like you have a vibe about you that's
like it's this is a compliment because
i never remember people like i'm
horrible and god me too
people call me out on it there's this
dude at the comedy store a couple weeks
ago
that i walked up to you know we were
talking and i was like hey
i'm kate and you don't matt oh he goes
kate you're at my birthday party
two years ago and we've been on shows
together and i was like dude i'm so
like i'm so sorry it's just first of all
to be fair to me though
his birthday party was a joint birthday
party with someone another comic book
yeah so it wasn't like i knew him i've
done that you know what i used to beat
myself up because i'd be like i'm so
rude
then there's a part of me that's like
okay hey we meet a ton of people doing
this like non-stop you're meeting people
b
it's like okay well if i don't remember
you it's kind of on you too
i feel that maybe but then i'm like is
that is that arrogant
you're like there's nothing memorable i
here's who i remember i remember people
who are
absolutely hilarious yes right i
remember people i would like to have sex
with
i mean for sure usually i don't always
remember that i don't even remember some
people
have had sex with really yeah dude it's
so pathetic that i can still
count mine that's i i mean it's pathetic
it's not pathetic
it makes me sad well i mean it's good i
think
it's there's no good or bad it's just
because i was out of the game for 10
years
yeah so i'm like playing catch up i'm
binge [ __ ] now i mean
i can't even put a range
on the amount of people i've had sex
with
good i feel like people should get out
there and find out what they like well
yeah oh to me it's almost creepy
i guess if you have a low enough number
it's not that creepy to know but at a
certain point
it's like oh you like if you had sex
with more than 20 people and you know
how many people you know
what are you doing like if you're
counting every single you're a serial
killer
there is someone that i who the [ __ ] did
i ask i can't remember who it was who
had a crazy high number it's like
677 or something but he knew the exact
number and he'd written them all down
that's nuts
that's creepy as [ __ ] you're right i
once tried to make a list and this had
to be like
half the amount of people that go just
because i was like well how many people
have i had sex with and then i started
making i was like
oh this is just gonna upset me because
i'm not i'm gonna i was like
what was that guy's name oh do you find
that all right well first of all i
should have i should have done this up
top because i wanted to say this for you
and we just started talking right away
that you guys can catch
jessica at the great plains uh comedy
fest
what is it september 13th through 18th i
mean if you're in saskatchewan canada so
they're you know
you might be i have a lot of canadians
that i feel like
i love being in saskatoon which sounds
like a fake town
have you been there before no it'll be
my first time really yeah i was just in
edmonton for the first time and i've
never been there
it was fun the crowds were great the
crowds were like comedy crowds i love it
everyone i've ever met out of canada is
so funny they're so cool
i imagine it's good comedy people i'm
excited they really were yeah i had a
great time there and and from what i
heard i haven't actually done stand-up
anywhere else in canada but i
i have heard that it's fantastic
everywhere i mean that's what i've heard
too i have a few canadian comic friends
and stuff and they
they all love it they love it it seems
great where did you grow up uh alaska
so that's next right because i was just
there and you posted for me which was so
sweet
oh yeah i was like i wonder if any of my
drunk high school friends will come out
back
didn't i was like almost terrified that
someone was going to come and be like
i'm
friends with jessica and i was like oh
no i would have been thrilled by the way
i thought
i probably would have been i'm ugh it
was really weird because i performed at
the
alaskan truckers association or i think
it was i also performed at the hard rock
which is an angler
just right then there was like an extra
like i guess it was like a corporate
kind of thing truckers yeah so they
hired me and dude i was like oh
these are my people i'm going to do
great here because i'm kind of dirty and
they'll love like it'll be a bunch of
truck drivers
like look at all these hats i own yeah i
was like i'm going to do
awesome and then i i walked in i almost
[ __ ] my pants because it wasn't truck
drivers
it was the people who owned the company
companies
so it was like suits oh no and it was
like a banquet hall and people were
really dressed up and i was they were
giving away awards and i literally was
like these people are gonna
and i had by the way shown up like
everyone's dressed up i'm in like
a flannel and a truck or hat you're like
i was i wanted to do truck stop comedy
yeah these are ceos yes oh my god that
was so
[ __ ] nervous and then i went up and
actually it went
fine except there was a kid someone
brought like their
10 year old kid what a nightmare i know
and he just stuck
headphones on the kid in the back of the
room
literal earmuffs literally that has to
be someone who's divorced
absolutely of divorce daddy's like after
this we'll go to denny's
it was like it was crazy but i did the
whole thing and it actually went fine
but then afterwards the best part is
the president comes up to me who's like
this 80 year old little 80 85 year old
man oh god
and he said to me he said i just wanted
to tell you
that i was out sick when they hired you
i was a little worried i was a little
worried that we made a mistake but you
actually did a fine fine
that's the most alaskan thing i've ever
heard when i found out we hired a woman
i was like oh no
women aren't funny yeah he was worried
so
but i did a fine that was the best part
the compliment was you did a fine job
fine thank you mister truck i was like
i'll take it i'll take it
did you have fun while you're up there
actually i did i had a really good time
um i drank a lot i always i'm going home
next week
uh and uh i'm terrified because i
haven't been drinking and my friends
basically bullied me into drinking when
i really
and then i have a problem where i will
not drink
just out you know i'm not like actively
like i'm not drinking i just am busy and
i'm a workaholic so i won't drink and
then
i get around my friends who are drinkers
and i try to drink
the way i used to when i drink all the
time and then i just die
like oh no that's so
funny no you totally can't you think my
tolerance is so low
right now because i was in vegas for a
week and then when i got back i didn't
drink for like four or five days and
then i had
i had two drinks and i was like wasted
the other night yeah i feel like i'm on
like i'm a one drink person now and then
i'm good
that's great though i mean it is great
as long as i only have one drink
right i'm a sloppy mess are you what
kind of drunk are you
i'm fun you're a fun drunk you're happy
yeah i'm very like life of the party i
don't usually get i'm not like an angry
crier
or anything that's your fin moments but
like do you have a cutoff where you turn
from happy drunk to sad drunk because i
do
uh i don't know i think i just always
drink so
quickly i go straight to blacked out
that's hilarious
you're like i'm happy that i passed the
[ __ ] out you know what i think it is
is when i'm super drunk it's just and i
don't know if this is true for everyone
but it's just the most of whatever
emotion
i have going on inside of me is what
comes out so if i'm drinking
and like i'm trying to cover up the fact
that i'm sad eventually i'm going to be
like
is stupid but or
angry or whatever i think that's normal
that's why they say i mean it's
basically truth serum whatever you're
feeling it's
more honest yeah i dated a guy who
didn't drink not because he was an
alcoholic just because he just
you know he didn't drink and is one of
those people every once in a while i
would slip
this is so awful oh my god you didn't oh
no so i'd slip
a little alcohol on purpose just to get
him to like tell me the truth
oh my god you're like truth roofing him
it's like a roofing for emotional
honesty
i didn't sleep with him i just got him
to tell me how he felt like that's
yeah that's wrong it's kind of [ __ ] up
now that i'm thinking back on it i feel
i was very young it was like the first
guy i dated out of my
mind like alcohol is has such a distinct
taste that if you don't
question what you're drinking like i
mean what's wrong with you i would put
it in
smoothies that were like super sweet oh
my god you're a crazy person i love
just to get him just like do you really
love me if you're wondering if i'm
insane like people don't understand when
i tweet that i'm like crazy and that's
why i'm single
and people it's so funny when when you
tweet about not you specifically but
anyone when you talk about any type of
like
intense emotional thing you do but but
you're not actively doing it all the
time people are like
i think you're making that up right like
i'll talk a lot about i have bits about
depression
yeah i'm not i don't walk around with a
rain cloud over my head because i'm like
i'm not gonna
bum everyone else out because i'm
depressed and people like i think you're
making it up or if i
if i'm self like deprecating like right
just because just because someone else
doesn't think i'm unattractive i'm like
i'm not a lot of a day where i feel
unattractive because you don't think i
am yeah
but people are like i don't believe you
and you like date me
find out yeah you want to find out
there's an easy way to i
thought about doing that i thought about
just dating a few people
like a few like one follower a week like
one twitter just so that it gets out
there that they're like oh she's
she real yeah it's not a character she's
doing yeah because people think if
you're just like a cute funny girl that
it's so easy dating
i think it's just it just you have more
people to choose from who are [ __ ] up
and you're [ __ ] up because well that's
the thing too is like complaining about
not being able to like find someone
people immediately go come on it's like
no i know i could date
a person yeah there are people out it's
not like i'm like
nobody will ever sleep with me or date
me but it's like
especially for female comedians it's not
the same as dudes like male comedians
have girls that are
hypothetically good catches coming up
after shows at best we have like
men who are like i like what you said
about your butthole oh i can't tell you
how many guys have come up to me i've
been like can i see that lazy boob
oh my god yeah my wife and i want to
take you by the wife and i was like the
do you get that all the time the closest
thing to a catch i'll get is a man who
already has a wife and is like we won't
have a threesome
all the time same i get like one of
those a month
yeah yeah i get it a lot and i'm like
well who's your wife yeah that's well
the only reason i don't even identify as
bisexuals because i'm afraid people
would realize how shallow i am about
women
like i'd be like she's not my type
meanwhile i date these men who are like
like by all social standards monsters
wait have you
done it have you gone home with a couple
i have so but i in my head
in my head i think that i have the
ability to or that like
maybe even if i will yeah uh
i don't know i also like i i don't like
the term sapiosexual because it sounds
so
douchey to be like i'm only attracted to
intelligence but like
it's personality plays in a lot for me
so like i can't have a person just be
like i'd [ __ ] you and me be like oh okay
i'm so wet no matter how hot they are
yeah right you just can't
guys don't get that there has to be some
connection connection or i don't get
turned on
it's like i mean yeah no i would say
that that
and that outweighs physical
whatever the physical thing is so much
more for me like if anyone looks at the
people i've been with like across the
board there's not like a
distinct physical type yeah but if
someone can make me laugh i mean
i'm not going to do like old bits i
wrote about it but like i literally
i will overlook all their flaws if
they're really funny i think that that's
normal like if you ask women what they
look for in a man every girl
says funny funny yeah yeah well cause
laughing feels good laughing is like a
connection i mean i did
a ton of shrooms last week and had this
whole like like
introspective uh experience about like
what laughter is and like where it comes
from but yeah
you feel connected to someone when you
laugh that's why i always tell people
that comedy shows are great dates
yeah because you take a girl to a comedy
show she's laughing the whole time in
her mind like
she's not necessarily distinguishing
that feeling
yeah i think it's like an aphrodisiac i
think yeah i definitely i have hooked up
actually now that i'm thinking about it
i have i don't very
often invite guys to come see my stand
up
i'm so terrified if a guy which is weird
because
i have almost exclusively dated comics
for those
really four years unintentionally but
like it
just happens and then uh but i don't
the idea of a man i'm like currently
dating seeing me perform is a nightmare
to me
yeah i try to avoid it most of the time
unless we're friends for like if it's a
guy i'm friends with
first and then we start hooking up i
feel a little more comfortable
with my sense so they already kind of
know who you are they know me because
that's what it is for me the reason i
don't want them to come is because i
feel like they're getting to know me
too fast yeah cause it's a heightened
like not even necessarily a heightened
version of who you are but it's like
a dumping of like this is who i am yes
and i have in
all the crazy too i because i talk about
being crazy on stage and i talk about
people i've slept with that i might not
want people to know and i know like it's
probably people are like but you're
saying it to a whole room of people but
it's so different when that one person
you don't want to know
yeah it's like okay and theoretically he
could like see a clip of me or like
i don't want to talk to a man and be
like i've slept with so many people and
yet here i am on a podcast being like
who knows
i know i know i'm with you um
oh my god i have so many questions about
growing up in alaska oh god how long did
you
live there for when did you move uh i
moved there in sixth grade from southern
mississippi and then i lived there
through high school so
however many years that is clearly not a
lot of math going on
uh like seven years you moved right
after high school yeah immediately i was
like goodbye
did you where in alaska was it anchorage
okay so you were kind of in a i mean
it's not a city
yeah like people are like where do you
live in an igloo or something it's like
no it's a
relatively normal city yeah a little
like
country it reminded me the town i grew
up in actually i'm from canton ohio and
it
totally reminded me it's just kind of
like a small city yeah
it's country a country-ish west vibe
people are nice
there's a tendency to be a little bit
backwards socially as far as like
i mean i definitely had some redneck
friends i was like a huge redneck i have
come a long way i don't say come a long
way i've just changed my perspective a
lot
well i mean my whole family my dad is
the biggest
redneck yeah like my dad is in i mean i
feel bad to say because he could watch
or listen i love
my dad so much but he's he's like he is
the guy with the mullet the beer gut
the nascar like that he smokes weed and
then he gets drunk and he calls me and
he's like the philosophical like the bob
dylan
hippie everyone i grew up with yeah
exactly so
it's actually embarrassing like when i
brought him i brought him out to l.a
and he only he had two requests he
wanted weed while he was here he wanted
me to get him
you know california weed yeah yeah and
he wanted to come to the comedy store
and i took him to the comedy store and
he wore
cut off sweat shorts oh my god
and a tank top and it was like july
i was so i was like oh my god yeah i
always like wonder that too because like
i'll see and i mean i love my mom but
she's a character and like
when other people talk about their
parents sometimes i get my head i'm like
is nobody else embarrassed of their
parents everyone has to be
because i'm like what are you doing why
are you in sweatpants and clogs in a
grocery store
like what don't do this to me do you
feel pressure here in l.a to like
i i used to just you know when i moved
here i would go to ralph's like i would
when i lived in ohio which is like no
makeup
when sweats go out you have to like i
just i don't feel like i have to look
good but i do feel like i can't just go
to the store
like with like looking like total
garbage you know
it's like and i still do find myself
doing that occasionally i also live like
on the east side which is like a little
out of la so it's a little away from the
kind of hollywood vibe but
even still when i do it i sort of feel
like i must look like i'm a crazy person
to everyone else
because everyone else is like a little
put together or fashionable and then i'm
like
i look like i'm homeless well i mean you
don't but i know what you mean like
and it's weird when you leave like i was
just in san jose and i was at the
grocery store and i saw
this couple there in their obvious
pajamas they both had on like flannel
pants slippers hoodies and i was like oh
this feels like home
like how normal getting out of a light
because i've been like going on the road
a lot and like going out of town and i
love it and part of it is because like
it brings back my self-esteem because
i'm like oh
i'm not a goblin monster i just live in
la where people are like injected with
things and
the most beautiful people from every
other part of the world are like let me
go to l.a
it is crazy but like anywhere like i
love going home
because and i mean i again i'm not doing
a bit but
if anyone hears my bits about alaska i
say something similar but like it
literally is like a self-esteem boost
because i'm like oh yeah oh i'm
hot here like yeah right
it's true though i mean and you can also
wear like the whole time i was in alaska
i had like no makeup and like a flannel
like
that was so great well you know it's
like i grew up in a city
where your personality went so much
further
as far as like making you attractive and
like yeah it was more about like
who's like cool to hang out with than it
was like who's obviously there are
people like
people like that person's heart or this
but it's like there wasn't this like
what what is that vibe in l.a that's
like
be beautiful and then i also think
there's so many people here who are just
i mean it's a magnet for narcissists so
not only are people like
good looking but people like think that
they deserve to be with someone who's
like the best looking and it's like
fall back sir right it is it is crazy
i think show business breeds narcissism
and
for sure have to be so self-involved
to be successful yeah and it's like i
even find myself
you know like i try i'm trying so hard
to hang on to like that midwestern like
that sweet nice
like not jaded but it gets it gets
really hard because you almost have to
be so
selfish at times you have to get like
almost like cut throaty or like
i hate that yeah i really do it's and
also it's weird though too because
there's a weird like
transition that happens not that like
i'm by no means successful right like
you're doing well
well i'm doing fine i'm like doing okay
like i'm
starting to take i also wonder how long
like
how successful do we have to get that we
don't feel like we're just doing okay
because if you look and never have
you've done yeah it's like yeah because
you
like if you take yourself out of it and
look at things on paper it's like okay
before i came here if someone told me i
was gonna do that this and that you'd be
like
oh my god so true wow but you get it now
and it's like
all right okay well what's next isn't
that crazy like i remember being a kid
and watching tv and i would have been
so stoked i always wanted to be on tv i
wanted to be on
that was my goal in life be on tv now
it's like yeah i did like that little
thing but like i mean right whatever
now i have a show i'm like well but it's
on it's on not on basic cable or the sun
like you know anything
on the subscription channel or like yeah
i mean it is crazy how
the more you get stuff the more you feel
like it's not like even i'm i should
just be happy to be
working as a comic yeah period but now
in my head i'm like oh but i want to get
a special like i want like i want the
next thing
right it makes you crazy but i think
that that's i think the people that have
success
are those people that are never
satisfied right because if you're
satisfied you can
stop working hard yeah you're like i did
it i may i've made it if i could treat
my dating life
like i treat my career which is be that
cutthroat and be like that
yes can you imagine like turning just
turning men down
like i needed something bigger you know
what's weird is like i
all right sorry you're wasting my time i
have to leave right
can you i do that i do that with guys i
think i get off on doing that to guys
that are really
successful that's funny and then i chase
guys that are like
losers i swear to god what's that i mean
i do the chasing
i get that the i mean i don't know if i
necessarily do it to guys that are
really successful but i get the appeal
to it because it's like
oh because especially in la is like oh
girls don't do that to them
right and i think i get pissed if they
think that it's okay for them to
actually
exactly because they're special it's
like you're just a man let me give you
like an example of this okay
i was just i went out five or six dates
with this guy who's a very
very successful actor like very famous
okay
and he's hot i love that i was into him
but then he started to do this [ __ ]
thing where he wouldn't make plans with
me
i get so can we just when just in
general is that like an la thing too is
it like i
just discussed this flow like yeah no no
i can't like my brain is like no you i'm
not hanging out with you if we can't put
it on a calendar
i'm too busy to to try to figure out
when you're available right and then i
i like i was just getting into an
argument with a guy friend about this
the other day because he was like man
this girl's getting so pissing me
because i won't make plans he's like i
just don't make plans i hit people up
when i'm free like hey what are you up
to you want to go grab a drink tonight
and she's always like you know well why
didn't you hit me up yesterday why don't
you make plans with me ever and he
really
can't wrap his he's like i don't make
plans with my boys
they don't get pissed i see their boys
don't value their own time
it's like that woman is busy right
screwy
i feel like it's a respect thing like if
you respect someone's time it's okay to
ask last minute because if i'm free i'll
come chill
but also it's like if you want to see me
you need to make plans is that crazy
no not at all i think it's insane when
people won't make plans
and uh a huge pet peeve of mine is when
people make plans
and cancel or like like guys like
loosely make plans and then
and try to be like well you know it
wasn't like a solid and it's like
yeah no it was for me i paid like that's
why i don't even date
i won't date uh like a guy that doesn't
make plans well no
i mean i think i'm not even dating in
general because like
i i like downloaded all the apps for
like a day
recently and then i was like get me out
of here because i realized like
oh my god if i take one night off of
shows to meet some man and he's
wasted your time that's how i feel you
know what you should do this is what i
do
i set them up if i have a show let's say
i have the lab factory eight
i'll be like i can do happy hour with
you at 6 30 i'll have one drink with
them
right before my show then if they if i
never want to see them again
eh i wasted one hour but i'm buying the
still at your show that's what i do
i make them come smarter but i won't let
them come to the show
yeah and then that's it and that's how i
do every first date it's always happy
hour before a show
dating lessons from you i also like get
in my head about dating because i am not
good with relationships either
and like and instead of just being like
this is just a date i'm like well i'm
going to leave a bunch anyway so like
it's not going to be able to be a
relationship and then like we don't even
want a relationship why am i panicking
about
the future with this person i've never
met maybe you overthink because i'm an
overthinker
i wonder if that's a comedian thing or a
woman thing probably both
yeah because i i like i almost say it's
a big comedian thing do you think so
because you're chronically analyzing
things yeah you're a good comedian you
have to analyze things yeah
i overthink everything well so so this
this famous dude right
so after he stopped trying to make plans
with me
i stopped seeing him anytime you hit me
up i would
i'd be like hey you need to make plans
with me i'm busy you need to make plans
for me i'm busy
so the last time we were supposed to
hang out we had
we had he hit me up and he was like hey
are you free tomorrow i'd love to get
coffee plans
yeah and i said great three o'clock
let's get coffee
i had to stop seeing him for like months
and this is a guy by the way that can
get
any girl but i finally realized if i'm a
dick to these guys
when they're a dick to me and they're
more interested they come they come back
yeah well because i i mean i think
that's a human thing too is that a lot
of times it's like oh guys like it when
you
when you're kind of like a little shitty
to them but it's like
i think we all just love the chase yeah
and it's i think it's not even being
shitty i think it's just being
hey i'm respecting yourself treating me
like yeah yeah not being like
whatever like makes you happy but what's
so annoying is that i i do that with
guys that have a lot of money or success
or fame i have no problem with these
guys who have nothing you're like
desperately trying
no i get crazy over there and i'll get
in my head and get crazy and be like oh
like
he probably has like so many women over
these guys that are like
and look at burger king riding a bike
and not to like
devalue them because i really like
clearly really like them but it's like
what's wrong with me that i think
everyone's hunting this guy down
because you're into him you think other
people must that's what our brains do is
if i'm into a guy i'm like everyone's
probably trying to sleep with him
do you go to the worst case scenario to
like
to the worst if they aren't returning my
text my brain goes straight to oh he's
[ __ ]
like that's it and then social media is
a nightmare because i'm like i'm going
through with what he's what is he like
what are
you oh what does he say that oh my god
i'm crazy and i'm like well obviously
he's sleeping with all of these women
and then it's like
wait i fave like sort of like or
whatever so many tweets it's like
i can't imagine if someone's done that
to me and just assumes i'm sleeping with
all the people whose tweets i like you
imagine i'm also very flirty on social
media and it doesn't always mean
something like
i i just have fun with it i've gotten
really good i used to do what you do
i've gotten so good at not doing it only
because
it only causes me pain it's like cutting
if i go look at their social media i'm
kidding i know
no you know i have gotten a lot better
at it but that is the thing that i
used to do and every once in a while
i'll catch myself slipping back into it
when i really like a guy and then i'm
like no
stop it what am i and it's like most of
it's just like guys liking
themselves being tagged in a tweet
anyway and i'm like i wonder if guys
you're just like me do this
i always wonder if guys do what we do
me too like do you think if a guy hasn't
heard from you for a couple days
he like goes on your instagram to see
what you've been doing
yeah well every once in a while it's a
good guy and he's shaking his head yeah
they do aaron's saying yes
aaron you can always hop in at any time
in this conversation by the way
we need a male voice over there yeah
yeah we'll talk we'll totally check your
social do you ever
like a girl's post to try to get her to
like notice you like if you haven't
talked to her in a while because i feel
like does that ever happen where all of
a sudden
of course like favorites are tweeting
yeah
if a guy favorites a tweet that's more
than like 12 hours old i know for sure
because nobody scrolls back to their
timeline yeah they're like just being
like
hey yeah that's a that's a passive
aggressive and by the way
[ __ ] move i think it's a [ __ ] move
here's my thing
guys do that to me though like guys that
have my phone number
that could easily just send me a text
instead we'll go back three days and
like a couple
of favorite tweets that's the thing i
tweeted that i think you tweeted
retweeted where i said uh
i mean i was just being silly but i was
like fave this tweet if you want to
flirt with me but you're you're too big
i retweeted that but you know what a guy
who i
have a huge thing for that i like had
hooked up with we had like we sort it
was like sort of dating it got really
intense and then we were both like whoa
hey what are we doing like and took a
step back or whatever
he liked that tweet and then he like
winked he like sent a wink
and then and he was just trying to be
silly but i like
lost my mind and i was like texting him
and i was like why would you do that
and like i went crazy and you did not
and he's like seriously crazy
what yeah no i like texted him well you
know what because i didn't notice
because i don't
have i have notifications turned off
because i'll lose my mind and somebody
else who i had talked to about this guy
just had been like oh i really like this
guy and then be like
it didn't work out and i'm sad and it's
weird and like i still like him
like you know just a friend without me
having seen like what happened yet i get
a tweet from that friend they're like uh
oh
subtweet war which i think maybe like
implanted the idea in my head that this
person was like trying to be
oh god it's so insane i had also just
come off the road and been in my car
alone for like 12 hours [ __ ] you
up it [ __ ] you does it give you time to
just
over analyze everything i went crazy i
was just on the road for three weeks
and right before i left town i basically
ended it with someone i mean i i wasn't
like we weren't exclusively together
but i basically was like i can't see you
anymore and i actually
blocked his number so he couldn't even
by the way when i block numbers usually
it's so that i can't tell that you can't
yeah no
i'm i am dude that's my problem moment
of weakness oh my god
no dude i am [ __ ] i can't i'm
compulsive when it comes to texting if
they don't answer
i get crazy i get so angry when they
don't just respond to me
i know you see it if i know they've seen
it like if let's say i text you at
midnight
and around 10 11 o'clock the next day i
know you're like at work and you never
replied
i get [ __ ] i guess
i'm like just saying that i get angry
and i send so many texts and i have like
a whole conversation i'm like
oh he read this and thought this now i'm
going to start like
thinking in their head well that's what
i did with that guy and then i was like
i
and i ended up calling him and i was
like look i need to talk to you about
this because i know i'm being insane but
like can i just talk to you about
it i started this this isn't even a guy
you're hooking up with oh no i had
hooked up with him
oh cause it was like i guess it's a
fling he was in another city and i was
on the road but like
i just like it got real intense real
fast which
is not to say like i have done that
chronically like i have a pattern
in relationships where i have been like
oh my god this person
let's be together forever and then a few
months later we could we get together
and then i'm like i don't want to do
this anymore
which is the thing i'm actively working
on and he has this guy had similar
patterns and we had talked about it
before we hooked up but i like
was just really into him and then that
happened and because it was a thing that
it's like it was a thing
did you guys have like amazing sexual
chemistry yes
yeah i i have a theory that the only
time women go
this kind of insane crazy no it's when
the sex is i have a whole bit about it
yeah like you just
you lose your mind and that's like
literally even in
to this person or is it just there's a
guy that i've been [ __ ]
well we're not anymore but had been
[ __ ] for like four
months or something and i i honestly can
say at this point
looking at it there's almost not one
thing about him that i
like it was just the second but i was
convinced that i was like
so in love with it like oh he's so great
and he like i could list a million great
things about him and then i look back
i'm like i don't think i could list
five things that i like we have in
common yeah but like the sex
it's just [ __ ] it's blinding aaron
does this happen to guys
i mean do you just do you com if the sex
is amazing do you feel love
i don't know do men ever feel love yeah
i don't think it's the same for the
girls i think men are just like uh
she's good enough and i think if men
find a woman who's like they think is
really good and like oh i've really got
this catch
then the like the woman has the
opportunity to bully them into being in
a relationship because like i don't know
if i'll find someone better so i guess
i'll just be with you if you want to be
i think the only relationships that are
successful are where both people
think that they are lucky where the guy
thinks that he
has a prize and the girl thinks she
doesn't need him that much oh really
yeah that i don't know in my experience
i guess
i imagine and this is from the
experience someone who has
a lot of experience with relationships
that don't work out but like
usually with me leaving though uh almost
exclusively with me being like i have to
get out of here
that's good but like i in my head i
think it's like both people have to be
like i can't believe that this person
wants to be with me
but i feel like you almost never get
that dynamic someone's always more into
it
i think there's always someone who's
more into it
than like my ex-husband i felt so
lucky with the way he treated me but in
the back of my mind
there was always a part of me that was
like but could i do
better and he never had that thought he
was like
i love you i love you oh yeah you're
amazing i worship you i worship you like
and i think that's why it lasted 10
years honestly yeah there was an element
that he was always chasing
i think the guy has to kind of always be
feel like this
could get away i kind of feel like that
or that there's you know it's weird like
i noticed recently
this territory thing too guys have where
it's like
yeah because you know i tried dating a
like a porn guy right
even with them even when they're that
open and they don't even care if you're
[ __ ] he didn't even care if i was
[ __ ] other people but
there's still this weird like
territorial thing i would notice where
if it was another
porn guy oh is that i noticed that porn
guy
has been hitting you up or like before
like if i was talking to an athlete
they wouldn't care about all these other
guys but if an athlete but the same
profession yeah
or it's like someone who i guess it's
like is it because
that person like rivals i think it's a
competitive hillary
yeah yeah where it's like i i want to be
like the athlete that you're into
like right like oh you can't you can
date that plumber but don't
hook up with another football player
that's my you know what i mean
i think i think that's like is it them
feeling like is it because the athlete
feels superior to a plumber but he's
like oh this athlete's like bringing the
same amount of things to the table
i don't know you know what people want
to say because it's like
i think in theory i could be i've always
figured felt
i could be in an open relationship in
theory but i've never done it but at the
end of the day it's like i
i don't think i'd want it to be don't
ask don't tell and i would like
be like i want to know what you're doing
because i think that's hot but also like
at the end of it all i want
to believe that like i'm better than all
of them i know
that's where it gets awkward right it's
like yeah but like i have the best [ __ ]
right
yeah well the guy should make you feel
that way like i know i had brad williams
on here
and um he talked about this on here so i
don't feel bad repeating it that him and
his girlfriend have threesomes oh yeah
i've seen him at a hotel
walk off with his girlfriend yeah yeah
and been like
amen but he told me that you know he's
like it's so important to me that like
after that girl leaves i always make
sure to [ __ ]
my girl again and like tell her how
amazing it is like he's like
it's so important to me that she knows
like she's number one that
well i think that's key to that like
that work yeah
and then because the way my life is
going
and where like my career is going it
long-term monogamy doesn't make sense
for me and also like
it would be really unfair of me to be
like hey man
uh wait here and [ __ ] no one i'm gonna
leave for months
yeah i agree with that i i it's weird
like
people kind of i'm a little more open
now to the open relationship
thing i always when i was married and
here by the way maybe
at the time i thought this was a clue
that i should know the marriage wasn't
right because when i was married
i was like can we please have an open
relationship like that's what i wanted
that's so funny
yeah and and people were like don't you
think that's a sign that he's like if
you're not
but i i was if you're not on the same
page sexually i've tried to make
relationships work where we just
and and not nothing against those men
but we're just very different actually
uh like not why no it's not gonna work
yeah actually you're gonna
snap and i need more i just i don't i
don't
mind it's weird but i don't mind a guy
that i'm with
occasionally hooking up like i could be
with a guy if he's like says a comic i
would never but say he's a comic
and he's on the road and occasionally he
takes a fan back to his room and they
hook up and he doesn't
they don't keep falling in love with her
yeah it's a one-time whatever
i don't really think i care no me too
you know what okay so that the person i
had
this like the fling with i talked about
earl like a few minutes ago and i was
like i went crazy
before we had hooked up or anything uh
but some somehow we were talking about
relationships because we were friendly
without any whatever yeah you know just
like
knew each other had mutual friends you
know comedy whatever uh
and he said something just in passing
about like his ideal relationship being
like
oh that i would have like sort of like
my main person and then like you know if
i hook up with her and i think i got
like starry-eyed at the idea of that
because i was like
yeah that's what i want i got all crazy
and it's like
me too i mean occasionally i actually
think it might be good for like
sometimes i look back at my marriage and
i'm like
i loved that guy so much we were such
good friends and everything else was
pretty much great if we would have
just the sex was a big thing yeah one
it's like
to think that you can get that a you can
everything from one person or that you
can give one person everything they
need yeah insane i think so i can never
be
like i'll never be an asian girl like if
that's a thing
i don't understand like i don't know if
there's things that like i'm not into
but a guy might be into an item it's
like
oh i don't need to throw away the whole
relationship just because i don't
want to spank you or whatever yeah
exactly but i think it might be healthy
i think it's 100 healthy i think
monogamy long term is
insane i think it's impossible uh just
uh i'm getting married yes what do you
think about it good luck with that yeah
aaron talk to us though for real like
what do you think about this because
you're you're getting married so
are you guys like traditional are you
just going to be just the two of you
forever
yeah and that's you're cool with that
i'm totally cool there
see that's like i love when it's also
like i
but damn it you know what as much as
that's true and i'm so damaged i can
imagine if i was a comic on the road
that would be
really hard yeah well that's a thing i
guess maybe if you're in a circumstance
where people are throwing themselves at
you it'd be hard well that's what also
especially for men
because women we have our whole lives of
having people thrown at us
and you get used to it but for a man
especially when he goes from like kind
of doing nothing to suddenly having like
fame
then women are like just hungry monsters
like
miss you have a show on what channel
like especially in l.a
isn't it so weird like to date someone
who's like famous
especially a male and think that like
and be like never touch anyone else is
like
get over yourself lady and it's like not
gonna happen the amount of people they
turn down
and then one slips through the cracks
that's what i always think is like when
people are like
yeah well you've had sex with a lot of
guys i'm like well let's focus on how
many i haven't had sex with because
that's
so big there's someone i can't remember
who it is that has a joke about that
and it's something like if i turn down
99 out of 100 girls i'm
it's still an a yeah you know it's still
i'm still doing well right well that's
the same i turned down like 99
of the men who want to [ __ ] me i've
still probably had sex with over 100 men
i mean it is crazy like i was in vegas
not too long ago um doing this like
celebrity golf tournament thing and i
was with
yeah exactly dude listen to this [ __ ]
one of the regrets of my life if you're
listening tyson i was with
rampage jackson and tyson beckford i did
not hook up with either
why that's the regret so i didn't hook
up with either but
i'm out with these two guys and rampage
is actually like a little more
um shy i mean he's not shy but he's not
the type to go
and just like start macking on some
girls not the ways tyson on the other
hand
hello this [ __ ] i mean like i i've
been out with like famous guys but i've
never been out with a guy that looks
like
tyson yeah of course in vegas he's
sitting there and i mean
it was like just swimming and women
would
not they could not control you could see
it on their face the way they were
looking at him
every girl just wanted to [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of him that's so funny
and he could have easily just probably
grabbed four girls and gone back to a
hotel room
and i mean i'm looking at that and i'm
just thinking to myself like
if this guy was faithful to one woman he
would be
jesus yes it would be impossible you're
going
crazy yeah and also i just i mean
but you know what all this being said
there is and i don't know how much of
it's like
uh this like wanting to find a person or
it's like social conditioning i don't
know what the mix is but there is always
still
a little like voice in the back of my
head or something that's like
but like uh because the way i really am
is like i don't think marriage is a good
idea like
it'll fall apart whatever but there's
still a little don't worry aaron but
there's still a little part of me that
has this like idealized like
but what if i found the right person or
like i would still love to find someone
that i'm like you know what i still
don't know if it'll work but
[ __ ] it let's try it like yeah well go
for it i love you enough that i'm
willing to give it a shot
yeah beautiful i mean i will say this
and aaron this is partly for you but not
just for you
that i there are a lot of things about
being married that i
do miss a lot like it's great to have
it's great to have someone who is such a
close friend that like
just there you just know like when
anything amazing happens you
automatically have something with them
having someone to tell that's what i
miss about relationships because i'll
get good news now and i'll be like yeah
and it's you can tell your girlfriends
and stuff
yeah and then it's even like sometimes
with that and of course your friends are
always excited for you but like
it all intermingles because it's like
all my friends also are in the same
industry so i'm like
does it come across like i'm bragging
instead of just yeah excited
yeah it's like this isn't even a thing
they wanted but i'm still gonna feel
like
right am i shoving it down your throat
i'm not yeah like how are they again
it's hard to brag it's hard to give good
news to other friends who are doing what
you're doing like you don't want to be
i know like i remember 2013 i had this
like
like great festival year when i first
kind of like that's when i left my
full-time job and like
i got into so many festivals but it was
just like hey
did you submit to such and such festival
and like waiting for them to be like
yeah i haven't heard anything and being
like
okay i know no you all like the guy
i was dating a guy who really wanted to
get into bridgetown
and i got into bridgetown and i got an
email and i was like oh my god this
email went to my spam apparently i got
into bridgetown and he's like
oh maybe oh maybe my email went to spam
and then i was like
did you find anything and he's like no
there's nothing here and i'm like
oh one minute it's like they want to try
to be
supportive for you but that's an awkward
dynamic of dating
someone that works in this one of the
pros and cons i won't i can't
i don't date comics just because i just
honestly the reason i saw
i stopped because i used to i didn't
date someone you're smart and strong
i mean i i just i get tired of talking
about it all
about all the time i don't know if i do
and also
there were there was a while where i
kept being like no more i'm not
i no more comedians but it's like i'm
not getting they're all
anyone else they're all you me yeah i
mean people have been on my [ __ ] lately
because i'm not gonna lie like i've been
hanging out with porn guys and it's like
been
it kind of for me it used to be
comedians because they were the only
guys i would meet then i hosted the avn
awards
all of a sudden all the guys hitting on
me but turned into porn guys all of a
sudden
and people were giving me [ __ ] like kate
don't you can't
if you hook up with more than one porn
guy you're the chick that [ __ ] porn
stars and i'm like
okay but i mean you mean i'm what every
guy wishes he could be
are you kidding me it is funny i had
dana moon on or i think it was
dana or maybe it was nicole amy i can't
remember which one was like
what you don't have to apologize you're
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] like a-list
[ __ ] like they're professional
[ __ ]
and you're apologizing for i think it
was
that had to be i think it was nicole but
i mean it's like
it doesn't the point is you get to [ __ ]
people who [ __ ] for a living
that's amazing i mean it's not really as
hard as you'd think to
to make it happen for you if you'd like
to yeah i mean just go on twitter
get tweeting hey
i see you um i have a
god damn you're such a great guest and i
hate that we only have a few more
minutes but i have a few more
i'm gonna ask you a few questions yeah
all right so question number one
is this this is a great question i got
from uh i think it was on instagram
what do you think about a guy who has a
girlfriend and he buys sex toys for that
girl and then they break up and he keeps
the sex toys
and he cleans them off to use on you
would you be
okay with that this is from a guy
because
they're really expensive and he's like i
bought my girlfriend a box of really
expensive
sex toys and when we broke up she wanted
them and i wouldn't give them to her
so i have them and i don't know if i can
use them or not i think
um it comes off creepy to me if a guy
were to be like i
already have this dildo it's like why it
is right
yeah i would be very much again no and
i'm not i'm not anti it's not like a
it's not like a weird bitter jealousy
thing it's like you use it
oh no it's german no it's just it's
germs it's also just like i'm sorry
you just been hanging on to this [ __ ]
ring or whatever or i mean i guess cog
rings are weird
well some of those vibrators are like
eighty dollars
i mean like a hitachi right well so it's
kind of weird now i'm thinking about
that is like
is it weird if i have a vibrator and i'm
letting a guy use it on me
or whatever is it weird that i use the
same vibrator with a different guy i've
never done that no
because i killed him i don't think that
because i use the kill i mean i get
those little ones and i'm like i don't
know where to find these batteries so i
just keep getting the little ones
i wear those down oh me too i gotta i
got actually i was at a party
after the avn awards and i got a
keychain vibrator
that was [ __ ] awesome because when i
was on the road doing stand-up sometimes
i would forget to bring something and i
had one of my keychain
and it died and i was never more sad
than when nothing died they don't last
long
don't last long i think i mean i'm like
sometimes i'm like these are probably
meant to last longer than they do with
me
i had a guy for hours i had to use a guy
uh i had a guy
steal one from exotica for me he there
was probably a free bowl of them or
whatever we need to steal it but like
god within two weeks that thing was dead
yeah they die quick if they're
if they're battery operations like
little ones but yeah like that's why i
like the hitachi ship plugs into the
wall
i mean i need to invest in one good like
this is for me
you don't have one you know what i used
to have two and then i dated a
psychopath who threw out my sex toys
no why he was jealous of my sex toys
some guys are i i wasn't i will say this
the entire relationship existed because
i was in a very like
low self-esteem place i hated him the
whole time and i was like i'll date this
guy he can't hurt me because i hate him
like
and then i just it was like that's pit
of self-loathing and then when i got out
of it i was like
this is i have dated several people that
it didn't work out with and some of them
it's like what a weird fit but i
regret none of it except that
relationship like it was so bad that i
was like i regret this really
yeah because everything else it's like i
grew from it i learned something about
myself whatever
even if they weren't great but like oh
what did he do he just was a garbage
monster
no i mean for a living uh was he a
comedian he
was attempting to be one but ah i would
say it's before i was
could call myself officially i mean i
was making money doing something else
and he was like
i can get some shoddy like probably call
center phone sales job he was he was an
awful human and just like
emotionally abusive a little physical he
didn't like he was like a grabber
not like a he was sounds like a winner
yeah
we might have dated the same person by
the way oh god
i want to think that you're better than
a david this person i date the biggest
[ __ ] this is
i mean like i i am so sexually attracted
to
because here's why because i like guys
that are like
really rough and bad like kills yeah but
those guys are not
very often good boys sweet yeah no
some of the sweetest people i've dated
have been like oh you're just like you
are in real life in bed and it's not
and it's like what do i expect but i
think i think people expect something
else from me in bed
when because like i'm very aggressive
and like powerful and like
not i don't like lay there like a day
like a dog but like
no in life i feel like but you're
submissive but i'm submissive so am i
that's because women that are super like
i think the alpha women
we seek out very alpha guys
because they make us feel feminine in
the bedroom you wanna feminine but i
think a lot of guys i end up sort of
like almost or like getting with
i think they assume i'm going to be like
dominant in bed and then they're like
they're surprised and they're like oh
that's not
you're i'm i don't do this either and
then and it's just this weird like
oh you're not like this guy's not gonna
[ __ ] me too light
that's i was hanging out with a guy
actually that i was like real into this
guy
but i never make a first move i just
don't i'm never the first one to kiss
the guy i'm not it makes me and i know
it's like
2016. it makes me feel ugly or like
unwanted
yeah it makes a move i need and maybe
it's because we're comics maybe it's all
women i'm not sure
i need a guy to make me feel very
desired yes i need to feel so wanted
otherwise it's like
uh i feel like i'm i don't know it feels
gross but then i'm like do men feel the
same way and we're all just trying to
force each other to take the heat
i don't think so i think guys think
they're way hotter than they are like
nine years old
it's like i mean there are people that
it's like how dare you
not be worshipping me which is insane
for me to say but it's like
do you do you think that there's a line
of women who are gonna [ __ ] you
like i mean i'm telling you i've dated
guys that like
here's what's crazy you know how they
say like to fake confidence like you
know it's like when you first start
stand up i tell people just fake
confidence on
pretend you think your jokes are [ __ ]
hilarious even if you're not sure
confidence goes so far i think the same
is true
in dating and i think guys that like
even if they don't have a lot of [ __ ]
going on
if they act like they do suddenly you're
like oh this person
the people to get i've been in
relationships with people and not until
i was out of it did i go like
i could also have like weird daddy
issues and stuff so it's like i think i
date someone i put them on this pedestal
of like
they have all the answers and like
they're doing everything well and then i
look back and i'm like
oh that person wasn't doing any better
than me yeah yeah i dated a guy that i
was like he's so
he's so smart and he could teach me so
much and then i look back and i'm like
that guy was so
[ __ ] dumb he couldn't put a sentence
together and the questions you were
asking these people and like just
accepting their wisdom and you're like
oh i was like you're
right i should do that oh god what is
wrong with us
i hope that there are some guys
listening who are as [ __ ] up as we i
feel like the most
[ __ ] up person to have a podcast about
dating but it's fine
it's gonna be failing for a reason uh
speaking of that
before we go i know i texted you and i
was like
i want to hear some bad date or bad sex
stories do you have any oh god
i mean half of the bad sex i've had is
probably
on my part but i mean you know it's just
that
it's mostly these like like super
submissive
or guys that like guys that have way too
much confidence i'll say this is that i
told a guy i was dating that i really
liked dirty talk i'm like hey like we
should
you know try to do like more of that
like trying to nicely be like hey
and then so he's on top of me
like we're having sex at another point
after i'd said this and he like whispers
in my ear but is just like
he's not saying anything he's just like
like i think trying to get up the
courage and dirty talk but it just was
like whispering
which whatever okay but then at the end
he commented on like yeah so i like
brought that in
like he was so proud of himself and i
was like how your parents hugged you too
much do you really think that that
you just mumbled in my ear like you
didn't call me a [ __ ]
those weren't words yeah i love that too
i love when guys call me like a horse
it's such a weird thing to to bring up
though because it's like
how do you tell them how do you tell
somebody and if you tell them to do it
it kind of ruins it too
yeah well that's the thing is like
that's the blurred line between like and
this is a weird thing to talk about is
like
consent because it's like i know of
course i of course
you should always have consent but like
i don't have to this isn't about like
the sex itself but i don't have to tell
you the things i like i wanted to just
happen
like the thing to do is you got to
communicate and say everything yeah but
like that ruins it for me
the consent line it's so i hate it's an
awkward thing to discuss and it is
tricky because i know it's like
no means no but there have been a couple
times that something has happened in bed
like okay like for instance the first
time i had anal
yeah i didn't really want to i kind of
wanted to but i was kind of
like right now and i was kind of like no
i don't i don't want to i don't want to
and he was like you're going to love it
just
relax we'll take it really slow and it's
kind of like starting to and i was like
no i don't think and then he was like
babe i'm already in yeah and i was like
oh it's not bad okay
okay yeah so i mean i can't believe i
just told that i'm blushing but like
but that would be an example of where
like i didn't there's moments like
that i'm like oh am i like i'm part of
the problem
right like same because i didn't really
say yes and like no means no and i was
and i didn't take a stand on kind of
saying no but i was kind of saying no
but i wasn't really sure
yeah so i think what we should say is if
if you mean
if you say no you gotta [ __ ] mean no
and you gotta make them stop or you
gotta find another word like
well maybe i i don't know i don't know
such a
question it's a weird topic we shouldn't
be on and go into it no means no
let's just say that yes no means no
unless you're [ __ ] me and her
yeah and then it's like
and then you gotta just read the body
language right but only with the two of
us
this is trouble for that i know well in
the last episode i said that
down syndrome people can [ __ ] as much as
they want and no one calls them [ __ ] so
i'm on a roll today i'm really killing
it but uh it's fine everything is fine
everyone's like good for you you found
someone i know i just i get upset
because you know i do like i just did
the thing in vegas where i opened for
don mareira in a bikini i did it because
he asked me to
that's fun yeah but people you know i
got so many people on my instagram
being like oh you have to pull your tits
out to be
funny or like whatever no my tits
aren't funny they just look great i mean
funny aside from that that my thing is
i'm like first of all he's my friend he
asked me to do it second of all
i get so pissed because i'm like if i
was doing this like if
if i'm [ __ ] bobby lee and i pull my
dick out on stage it's funny because i'm
a
short pudgy [ __ ] guy well you know
it's
it's a sad truth though and it's like a
thing that i'm like guilty of saying
is that like nudity is only funny if you
have an ugly body
it's true but it's also like there's a
problem in comedy which
i mean we don't even have time to go
into this where it's like people
it's like there's this idea that like we
can't accept a woman who's
also beautiful that it's like that it's
like oh well
she's pretty so she must be using that
to get ahead and it's like
you use whatever you have and the thing
is i used to be so
upset about that like i used to be like
yeah the these
you know and it's like oh i'm just mad
because i'm not that hot
and so i adjust only have this thing to
use
but it's like you know what you mean who
cares my thing is it's like you use
whatever
you have it's like this it's like these
are all your tools
would you not like brad williams going
on stage and never
talking about being a dwarf of course
he's going to do material about being a
dwarf he's a dwarf
why wouldn't you use the most obvious
thing yeah and a visual
i'm not saying like that people should
do stand up in bikini because i honestly
even when he asked me to do it i was
like i don't know if i should do it
again i did it once just to prove the
point that it could be done
but yeah like i wasn't even sure but
then part of me is like
if i'm gonna be this girl that's like
own what you are
and don't [ __ ] be afraid to like
embrace it embrace your sexuality
embrace whatever
i can't then be like but i won't i can't
do that yeah
yeah [ __ ] it whatever who cares i don't
know how i got on this soapbox
this was a weird episode but i'm really
happy with it i feel like we covered a
lot of ground
yeah by the way are you single right now
i am you are
yes i love people
i love people i don't know i'm very
single but
i'm mentally like thinking about the 800
that got away all the time do you know
what i think we should do that would be
a really fun episode of the show and we
should really do it aaron we should talk
about this
we should get lav mics one night and
like me you dana moon and nicole amy we
should just go to a bar
and we should just hit on guys and then
we should edit it together into an
episode and see what happens i would
love that wouldn't that be fun that
would be should all go together could we
do we have loves at this place can we
make that happen
we'll figure it out absolutely
like there's no look at behind us what's
on this is what we have here a flat
screen with nothing on it
uh dude you're amazing thank you so much
for being here you're [ __ ] red you
guys
please follow her at jms comedy on
everything and go
see her she's going to be saskatchewan
in september
uh africa november she's [ __ ]
everywhere
and i love you jessica michelle
singleton you're awesome
i love you thanks for having me of
course thank you guys for listening
follow me at kateq funny and i will talk
to you all soon
bye dude you're such a good guest
oh